[Musik]
corona vorschriften verletzt 500
mitarbeiter eines
landwirtschaftsbetriebs in niederbayern
müssen in quarantäne
trauer um urgestein der sozialdemokratie
hans jochen vogel ist im alter von 94
jahren gestorben
testpflicht für reise rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten dafür spricht sich fdp
chef lindner im zdf sommerinterview aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
unseren nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag
und auch der sport fehlt nicht norbert
lehmann ist da ein stück von mir
und wieder gibt es einen corona
massenausbruch in deutschland diesmal in
niederbayern auf einem gemüse bauernhof
in mamming landkreis dingolfing landau
dort haben sich mindestens 174
erntehelfer mit dem virus infiziert das
landratsamt hat das gelände daraufhin
absperren lassen und jetzt befinden sich
fast 500 menschen auf dem hof in
quarantäne
jutta sommer bald großer umzug auf
diesem bauernhof im niederbayerischen
mamming infizierte erntehelfer werden
von nicht infizierten getrennt der
gesamte betrieb ist abgeriegelt und
steht unter quarantäne
die kritische obergrenze von 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner ist
im landkreis überschritten
trotz der hohen zahl der positiv
getesteten handelt es sich nach unserer
einschätzung momentan um einen in sich
geschlossenen personenkreis gurken
werden hier im landkreis dingolfing
geerntet vor allem von osteuropäischen
saison arbeitern die in solchen
wohncontainern untergebracht sind genau
das könnte die ursache für die erneute
massen infektion unter gastarbeitern
sein so die einschätzung eines virologen
der fordert dass die menschen eben nicht
mehr so eng in ihren zimmern
zusammenhocken dass man sich maßnahmen
überlegt dass man mehr räume anmietet
und wirklich die räumliche enge so weit
es geht eben auseinander zu zerren
bayerns gesundheitsministerin melanie
huml vermutet dass dem betroffenen
betrieb die vorgeschriebenen hygiene
konzepte nicht eingehalten wurden die
konsequenz dieses ereignis heute ist
auch der startschuss dass wir hier die
erntehelfer eben schwerpunktmäßig testen
wollen sicherlich erstmal hier im
diesem im landkreis benachbarte
landkreise um zu sehen ob dieses infekt
geschehen sich hier weiter in betrieb
neben ausbreitet erst wenn feststeht
dass nicht nur der eine betrieb in
mamming betroffen ist könnten starke
einschränkungen für den landkreis oder
die gesamte region zur debatte stehen
wir vor dem betroffenen betrieb in
mamming stets alles für uns sarah
offenbar wurden hygienevorschriften auf
dem hof nicht eingehalten wie muss man
sich das vorstellen
es hat ein hygiene konzept gegeben ein
abgenommen es für diesen gurken hof
hinter mir das hat der landrat heute in
der pressekonferenz berichtet und er hat
sicherlich ärgerlich reagiert als er auf
diesem bauernhof angesprochen wurde
denn dieses hygiene konzept das sieht
eigentlich vor dass die saison arbeiter
die erntehelfer in feste schichten
eingeteilt werden in feste gruppen und
innerhalb dieser schichten nicht nur zur
arbeit gehen sondern eben auch zu den
mahlzeiten und auch die duschen und
nasszellen zusammen benutzen und dass es
aber zwischen diesen gruppen keinerlei
kontakt geben darf und genau das scheint
nicht funktioniert zu haben also es gibt
hinweise dass es kontakt auch engen
kontakt zwischen den einzelnen schichten
gab
und deswegen ist der ausbruch jetzt
nicht auf eine eine einzige schicht
beschränkt sondern hat den gesamten
betrieb erfasst danke für diese
informationen sarah schon war das in
mamming schauen wir auf die entwicklung
in ganz deutschland da zeigt der trend
die zahl der neuinfektionen nimmt weiter
zu
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 550 menschen mit
dem virus angesteckt das ist der höchste
wert seit vier wochen
die britische regierung hat überraschend
reisebeschränkungen für spanien verhängt
wer von dort zurückkehrt muss ab sofort
für zwei wochen in quarantäne
london reagiert damit auf die steigenden
infektionszahlen in spanien
der reiseveranstalter tui kündigte an ab
morgen seine flüge von großbritannien
aufs spanische festland zu streichen
für deutsche reisende gebe es keine
auswirkungen
nicht nur in der spd galt er als
politiker mit unerschütterlicher moral
und als großer europäer nun ist hans
jochen vogel im alter von 94 jahren
gestorben
minister parteichef kanzlerkandidat
jahrzehntelang prägte er die spd während
sein bruder bernhard in der cdu karriere
machte hans jochen vogel sweg begann in
münchen vorher schon früh mit gewaltigen
problemen fertig werden musste manfred
anders erinnert als oberbürgermeister
hatte er für 1972 die olympischen spiele
nach münchen geholt hans jochen vogel
wollte heitere spiele aber arabische
terroristen überfielen israelische
sportler nahmen elf geiseln alle starben
bei einem gescheiterten
befreiungsversuch durch die spiele
sollten weiter gehen sie ist ein versuch
deutlich zu machen dass die olympische
idee auch einen solchen anschlag
überwinden kann es kam die zeit des raf
terrors arbeitgeberpräsident schleyer
war entführt und ermordet wurden vogel
ra damals bundesjustizministern das
nicht verhindern konnte
das steht mir auch heute noch bedrückend
immer wieder vor augen
vogel wurde eine art parteisoldat für
aussichtslose fälle für kurze zeit
regierender bürgermeister von berlin
auslöser kanzlerkandidat und
spd-parteivorsitzender als willy brandt
dieses amt aufgeben musste er blieb bis
ins hohe alter agil
obwohl er an einer schweren erkrankung
insbesondere begleitet mich eben seit
einigen jahren der herr parkinson dress
kein angenehmer begleiter zu seinem
neunzigsten geburtstag gratulierten
viele weggefährten und hans jochen vogel
fasste hier sein lebensmotto zusammen
man hat sich bemüht diese worte hätte
ich mir übrigens auch auf meinem
grabstein verstehen den lebensabend
hatte er in einem seniorenheim verbracht
auch das wohl überlegt wie es seine art
war bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier zeigte sich vom tod hans
jochen vogels auch persönlich sehr
betroffen
vogel habe sich für toleranz respekt und
ein friedliches zusammenleben in unserer
gesellschaft eingesetzt
bayerns ministerpräsident so wurde ich
den vogel als herausragende
persönlichkeit die über parteigrenzen
hinweg durch ihre glaubwürdige politik
höchstes ansehen genoss fdp chef
christian lindner vermisst eine
wirkliche test strategie um neue corona
infektionsherde zu verhindern
im zdf-sommerinterview sieht er
besonders bei reiserückkehrern
handlungsbedarf
christian lindner kommt hygienisch
unangreifbar aber politisch angegriffen
zum sommerinterview in düsseldorf die
fdp nach einigen umfragen unter fünf
prozent der fdp chef nach einigen
fehlern in der defensive
erklärungsversuch
gegenwärtig ist in deutschland eine
andere politik populär
das sieht man an der fast romantischen
verehrung für herrn söder in dieser zeit
der pandemie der verunsicherung genießen
die politiker besondere zustimmung die
mit sehr harten maßnahmen reagieren das
ist aber nicht unsere dna zu den
maßnahmen die lindner gut findet gehören
corona tests für urlauber die aus
risikogebieten zurückkehren nicht nur
als service sondern als pflicht wer sich
in ein risikogebiet freiwillig begibt
als tourist der wird dann mit einkaufen
müssen dass er für diesen test auch
bezahlt das ist eine frage der eigenen
verantwortung in meinen haben den
umstrittenen thüringer fdp chef
kemmerich fordert lindner auf auf eine
weitere spitzenkandidatur zu verzichten
aus rücksicht auf das ansehen der fdp
er ist ja gewissermaßen zu einem symbol
geworden es geht ja gar nicht nur um die
person kennt man erst zu an symbol
geworden und da macht sinn sich aus dem
spiel zu nehmen und herr kemmerich weiß
auch dass in den anderen 15
landesverbänden sicherlich seine
kandidatur nicht auf große unterstützung
treffen würde keine zweifel lässt
lindner an seinen eigenen plänen der
partei und fraktionschef will die fdp
noch einmal in den wahlkampf führen
und nun zu dir norbert grund zum letzten
spieltag in der englischen premier
league
da war es heute nochmal so richtig
spannend einen dreikampf um die beiden
letzten champions league plätze zwischen
chelsea und im direkten
duell leicester city und manchester
united gerade noch mal gut gegangen
der dreimalige champions league gewinner
manchester united hat sich die teilnahme
an der europäischen königsklasse nach
dem 2 0 bei leicester gesichert bei
einer stunde der torgefährliche war die
mit der bis dato größten chance für den
außenseiter
dann bricht maximal durch wird in die
zange genommen elfmeter für united der
portugiese fernandez verwandelte
nervenstark zum 1 0 ein treffer der
manchester united unter den
umsatzstärksten vereinen der welt halten
dürfte das torwart schmeichel in der
nachspielzeit dieser lapsus zum 0 2
passiert ist dann eher eine randnotiz
bayern münchen ist heute ins
mannschaftstraining eingestiegen
der deutsche meister hat das duo will ja
schon in der tasche und peilt jetzt das
triple an
und das alles mit großem
selbstbewusstsein 13 tage noch bis zum
champions league rückspiel gegen chelsea
trainer hans flick startet die
vorbereitung mit 31 spielern und zeigt
sich sofort beeindruckt sie ist sehr
fokussiert sie hat enorme qualität im
training und vor allen dingen natürlich
auch enorme intensität diese corona
saison könnte ihre krönung mit dem
dritten titel erhalten ab sofort
arbeitet der fc bayern an dieser mission
die 2013 bisher einmalig gelangen die
bereitschaft der mannschaft ist einfach
auch da ja dies ist so anzunehmen und zu
wissen okay wir müssen ein bisschen mehr
machen nur zwei wermutstropfen paar war
verletzte sich am knöchel fällt drei
wochen aus und seine ist für die
champions league im august noch nicht
spielberechtigt das war schon bleibt der
blick aufs wetter und da startet die
neue woche im westen und nordwesten mit
einzelnen schauern sonst bleibt es meist
trocken im süden viel sonne 20 bis 34
grad so viel von uns für den moment
schön dass sie dabei waren und
hoffentlich bleiben denn hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit dem sommerinterview von
chuck und energy mit christian lindner
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder bis
dahin machen sie es gut